hi thanks for coming it's nice of you to
come
for that nice introduction we have 22
shops now so San Francisco LA New York
Tokyo half dozen and most sorry if I
stand here I can see my slides I can see
my notes I have my remote control behind
the podium makes me a little more
comfortable so before we start I thought
it would be helpful to give you a little
idea of what I thought we should go over
today I think we should talk a little
bit about how Blue Bottle coffee started
but not too much a little bit about what
I did before that not too much
I want to tour we'll have a lightning
round of slides touring all of our shops
and so that that might be fun
maybe I know that the word case studies
I'm familiar with that word you might
have a couple of those I know that
people talk about those two words a lot
and talk about constraints on our growth
a few things like that talk about the
product which is so important maybe your
most important thing people who make it
there'll be a few slides I'm getting
better at PowerPoint but I'm not that
great at it
I was thinking on the ride down about
John Cage Merce Cunningham is anybody
study John Cage Moore's Cunningham very
good John Cage's composer Merce
Cunningham as a choreographer and they
would work on pieces that were to be
performed together but they would never
put them together and tell and tell the
actual performance they'd work on them
separately the music and the dancing
would go would be constructed separately
and then they just put him together I
thought it would be it's such an
interesting way of thinking about
PowerPoint I would love to see a
presentation where the slides were
totally divorced from the content of the
speech and and you the audience would
have to kind of project your own meaning
into these divergent things so it might
be a little bit like that so here we go
yes so using the word slides I usually
use the word slides to refer to
playground equipment so that's that's
kind of where I stand was that um so
that's a coffee roaster it's a pro bot
coffee roaster it's illustrated by
Michelle Rhee's to be our professional
artist at Blue Bottle coffee um I
started Blue Bottle in 2003 and before
that I was a clarinet player as a
classical musician and that didn't
prepare me very well
for business or did it and so that's
what we'll talk about now so as a
classical musician as a clarinetist I
basically from age 12 to age 34 all day
every day thought about my art so I
thought about getting better at the
clarinet you know I made a living I was
decent at it I kind of got the jobs that
I didn't want to get and didn't get the
jobs I really wanted but it's hard to
make a living and and I did some
interesting music I had a dream of how I
wanted to sound but it was very hard to
achieve that dream it was this
dysmorphic sort of the sonic equivalent
of anorexia nervosa I could never really
appreciate the work I'd done or how I'd
done it and the longer that I played
sort of the more lost I become became I
had this yearning to make beautiful art
and nothing ever seemed to be beautiful
enough it was a hard way to live but I
had a nerdy little hobby
I would roast coffee on a perforated
baking sheet in my oven and it was very
sort of crude way of roasting coffee but
I loved it so much it it you know
obviously it filled the kitchen with
smoke and made my ex-wife who's a opera
singer at the time very angry with me
but I got this idea of coffee being a
fresh food I was a farmers market
shopper and I didn't see coffee being
treated in the same very personal way a
very fresh way that that these great
farmers that I would patronize treat
their products and I thought that was
odd at the time I was doing this was in
the mid 90s I'm afraid to say it was a
long time ago
I you literally couldn't find a coffee
produced commercially that had a roast
date on it the major the major Coffee
Roasters weren't talking about freshness
in the way that I really believed was
important with coffee because I would
drink the coffee ever sit at home they
won it tasted a certain way day to day
three it had an ark it would peak a few
days later and then decline and that was
so exciting for me that was very
compelling for me and I couldn't
understand why the coffee that I liked
so much that I roasted at home I
couldn't have that experience of
drinking it somewhere else and so you
know this idea of being so miserable at
what you're doing that you have to find
a change you have to change something
and that's where the idea of stopping
playing the clarinet after so many years
and going into coffee chasing this nerdy
little dream that became more and more
crystallized in my mind because the
farmers market is a great way of under
if you don't really know business it's a
great way of understanding Commerce at a
very basic level you can I mean what do
you do you show up once a week you give
somebody money for something they give
you this thing you know the producer it
goes back to where they produce it they
farm it they make it and they repeat it
the next week they bring it back you
bring back some more money you know it's
like you don't need to go to business
school to kind of understand how that
works so that's what I did in 2003 I
signed a lease 186 square feet and in
the temazcal district on 51st and
Telegraph behind the restaurant Dona
Tomas former potting shed and I got a
little roaster that roasted about seven
pounds three kilograms and I started
doing it and I didn't realize until I
started that really I should have had
more money to credit cards to musicians
credit cards
weren't technically enough you know
there are a lot of things I should have
known but I'm glad I didn't it's good
not to know things sometimes um but what
did I do
I'm gonna skip this one 2008 and so
that's how many square feet that's how
many kilograms at once I could roast and
that's where I did it that little
potting show and you know what I loved
about coffee is yeah I had this such
attachment and dedication to the
profound as a musician as a musician
we're constantly being shown the work of
of the West's great geniuses that we are
exposed to the profound our whole
careers and that's a lot of pressure you
know the profound is a lot of pressure
and um what I realized that freed me in
my life in coffee was it didn't have to
be profound it just had to be really
really good and really really good as
rare in the coffee business it was at
that time and it's still quite rare now
even though it's a little less rare than
it used to be but you know this this
being freed from the shackles of
perfection was very liberating for me
and I realized that there were certain
habits I had as a musician that actually
were very helpful for me in coffee
people think that what musicians do is
they put on their tuxedo and they go
onstage and they play the concert and go
home but actually most of the time what
musicians do is they sit in a room by
themselves with their instrument doing
the same thing over and over and over
again all day every day
for many many years in a row and the the
the task of a musician is to be slightly
better at the end of the day than you
were at the beginning this notion of
repeating to perfect repeating repeating
repeating to perfect that was a that was
the standard that a musician had other
internalized standards were
you know I had the ability to imagine
sensory outcomes as a musician you're
constantly thinking about this sensory
experience that you want to provide to
somebody to your audience and as a
musician you're thinking about service
being in service to the composer being
in service to your audience so that
those those attributes of being in
service imagining sensory outcomes
repeating to perfect actually are very
helpful to me even now I mean what is a
what do you do when you roast a batch of
coffee at 17 minutes out so you can be
bored if you're roasting all day for you
know 13 to 17 minutes per batch or you
can be fascinated or you can try to make
every single batch slightly better than
one before you can imagine a century
outcome by cupping the coffee at the
roaster you can imagine sensory outcomes
in terms of presenting them to guests
you can be in service of the coffee
growers can be in service to the people
that come into your cafes you can be in
service to the people that are serving
our coffee so all of those attributes
actually kind of came in handy
surprisingly so the one thing that I
loved about the farmers market is you go
to see farmers lit up farmer little at
the Ferry Plaza Saturday market and he
has the best potatoes and he's got a
ten-by-ten easy up and he has his
potatoes under them you go to see farmer
Olson when it's clementines season and
he's got the best clementines
he's got a ten-by-ten ez-up and he sells
them under them a lot of farms same
there's not a lot of marketing budget if
you're at the farmers market there's not
a lot of brand and goes on what are they
focused on wholly and primarily and that
is their product the product is
absolutely primary and that was a great
lesson for me that's how I felt about
our coffee that's how I still feel about
our coffee is that experience of
drinking our coffee is absolutely
primary there's nothing more important
than giving people that experience
everything else you know
sure we have to think about how the logo
looks and what color the walls should be
and that kind of thing but everything is
about removing obstacles everything in
terms of design branding that word um
everything is about removing obstacles
to that primary experience of giving
people this product so on that sobering
note I thought we'd take a little tour
of our cafes have a little break
oh sorry okay yes I will
I'm not a mumbler I'm more of a ponderer
I think but I'll try my best so this is
a kiosk we'll talk about that more it's
oh it's in inter garage in Hayes Valley
in San Francisco a little kiosk
that's our shop in mint Plaza we'll talk
about that more in San Francisco also
open on a piece Melling alleyway
that's the Ferry Building it's a busy
place that's a roastery in Oakland
that's our shop on 18th Florida and San
Francisco
that's Webster Street or WC Moore's
building up a Broadway Oakland's first
truck showroom that is the most
beautiful courtyard on University Avenue
that's our palo alto shop I love that
courtyard parenthetically that style of
architecture sprung from the 1915 Pampa
cific exhibition it's very interesting
history if you see the Spanish style
buildings around town that's Market
Square Sansom in the financial district
the old Standard Oil HQ and that's San
Francisco then we opened in New York
we'll have more to talk about New York
that's our roastery that's in Chelsea
Rockefeller Center the High Line Hell's
Kitchen Cobble Hill Bryant Park and
that's in Los Angeles
that's the Roasterie there Arts District
Abbot Kinney Beverly Grove Echo Park
soon to open in Culver City and that's
Tokyo Kissimmee Shirakawa where the
Roasterie is a yama and is soon to open
in shinjuku so that's what we've done so
far it's taken 13 years to get that many
this time next year we'll have maybe
instead of 22 will have 35 that's a fast
lightning round the existing models when
I was starting coffee there were
basically two of them this is the Pete's
location in walnut and Vine that all the
signs and symbols were around buying
beans more than drinks very very darkly
roasted coffee scooped out of bins it
was a very you know it's very much about
dark roasted coffee not so much the
flavors of the origin but the flavors of
the roast there's an art to that and I'm
not disparaging that model I just wasn't
interested in that
I was interesting in more origin tastes
and I was interested in more layers and
different change differentiation of the
tastes of the coffee the other existing
models sort of this Italian based that's
Caffe Trieste Italian based cafe that
was kind of messy you know the when I
was starting in coffee there were and
there's still many many cafes like this
that are just sort of messy they have
like a they're more places to rent space
they have couches and messy bulletin
boards and and distractions from the
coffee rather than focusing on the
coffee
they've got muffins wrapped in plastic
they've got you know all kinds of 20
different fonts on display you know that
that's a definitely a model but I feel
like what I was interested in was the
product first and what my task at Blue
Bottle in our team's tasks at Blue
Bottle is is to focus on removing those
distractions to give people this primary
experience of tasting this delicious
thing and the best way we
possibly presented so when I opened we
did the farmers market and that got very
busy and it was very fun a very stripped
down you know no electricity no running
water so definitely art was about
constraints and that in that way and so
case study number one I guess you could
say was our kiosk in Hayes Valley in
2005 January 23rd 2005 we opened in
Hayes Valley and at the time that
alleyway was a dent in our way that
smelled like pee
it was not the most hospitable place to
be but I knew the friend of mine owned
that building and he and I didn't have
enough money to open a cafe and he said
well why don't we do something in my
garage and I said sure
and that that's what we did and it was
very odd it's still a little bit odd now
but it was very odd place to open a cafe
but I think about the beginner's luck
that that represented had I had more
money I would have felt the pressure to
open a more traditional seeming cafe but
this way because the architecture was so
different the the way that that it's
averted the expectations of the guests
in an interesting way I think it made
them more receptive to having a
radically different approach to making
coffee we ground everything to orderin
and prepared all the brewed coffee to
order we didn't have it in urns we had a
six drink menu no sizes no flavors every
milk drink was steamed to order with
latte art on the top it was very very
different had I done market research I
would have asked people questions like
oh do you want to buy a coffee that's
roasted lighter than the coffee you say
you like do you want to pay a little bit
more for coffee do you want to wait a
little bit longer for coffee do you want
to have fewer choices among drinks or
sizes or flavors and you know I would
have heard no no no and no but
fortunately I didn't even know what
market research was
so we just did what we thought was the
most delicious thing we could possibly
do and and it worked it was not so busy
at first but it totally worked
you know we had the first pide powered
machine in California PID stands for
proportional integrative derivative it's
a way of regulating boiler temperatures
to a very very fine tolerance and so we
were focused on accuracy and consistency
right now it's you know it's much more
common to have those machines out now
but at the time it was a little bit of a
Frankenstein machine this guy I knew
from the farmers market like he was a
scientist or something installed it so
the fact that the surroundings changed
people's expectations for and made them
more receptive to the coffee we were
getting the products that we wanted to
put in their hands that was a great
lesson for me people even people now
talk about like oh the coffee market so
saturated saturated market and they were
talking about it then - I love that it's
kind of a liquid metaphor - saturated
market but if you know saturated then
saturated now but it's also what else is
it saturated with its saturated with
interest its saturated with passion its
saturated with people trying to do great
work its saturated with customers you
know saturated with attention and also
saturated with a lot of models that
aren't really executing super well so I
don't know if there's a generalization
that's safe to draw but I've always you
know haven't been too bothered about
this idea of saturated market there's a
story I was there long ago I would roast
coffee and I would bring it over to the
kiosk and I dropped off coffee one
afternoon and I was kind of hanging out
in the back and a couple came and it
wasn't very busy it wasn't a line and
there's man and woman and they were
standing like I it looked as the woman
he was with and just you know his paws
and he said I like this place
he's looking around and his person he
was there like looked at him was like
why and they thought for a minute he
said I don't know and that's so
memorable to me like so did that
creation of the ineffable he couldn't
put his finger on it he couldn't say why
he wanted to be there why I like to be
there that was a very powerful lesson
for me there's so many businesses now
that like try to beat you over the head
with their message their brand story but
I think if we leave enough space people
can feel like they can relax and not be
there not being lectured at they can
think about it they can pause they don't
have to be told what to think and how to
feel I like that um so case study number
one um in 2008 well to back up
I had a friend I have a friend his
name's Jay gommi he works in Japanese
coffee industry for a big company called
UCC I met him at the farmers market long
ago and he started telling me filling my
head with the way that people make
coffee in Japan and the style and a
culture of certain places that make
coffee in Japan there's a very
old-fashioned fusty dowdy type of coffee
house called the kiss at 10:00 and he
was talking to me about that and in 2008
I finally went there and I went to this
place I went to a bunch of old-fashioned
places the kiss at 10:00 and I was
totally blown away with just how they
did it
you know the perfection it wasn't my
taste exactly but the perfection with
which they were able to execute their
vision and a very personal vision that
they had in these kiss attends was
remarkably inspiring it was stunning
that and and the connections with my
former life you know they had absolutely
mastered repetition to perfection they
had absolutely mastered imagining a
sensory outcome and duplicating it
it was cohere
it was just this rarefied excellence
there's this word called coda waria
that's a beautiful word that sort of
means that the imprint of the founder of
maestro whatever you want to call him
permeates the space and this idea of
code owari
was very strong in these places and very
inspiring to me
anybody studying jean-paul Sartre very
good you're studying very good you're
setting a good example
he's um philosopher I think it's out of
his book nausea he has a line everything
has been figured out except how to live
which i think is very inspiring but the
kiss at 10 being at the kiss at ten gave
me a little glimpse of maybe how to live
it felt like serving coffee was immoral
act it felt like a deep-seated sense of
responsibility to the product and the
guests and the service felt the same as
I felt like in service to a composer
felt in service to this vision that they
had so I felt at home in these places it
was very strange to be 6,000 miles away
and to feel at home I'll tell you one
story about HUD so this place other
places do it too you see that wall of
cups behind the gentleman there if you
sit at the bar you order something first
thing he does after he understands the
order he'll look at the wall of cups
look and it took me a few times going
there to figure out like what was he
doing there's 150 cups just grab a cup
man but he was figuring out like in that
moment for my order for this guest what
is the best possible cup to use in this
context what is the cup that I need to
have my coffee in but don't realize it
yet what is the cup that's going to
enhance my experience and that pause
I've always loved that power
it's not very efficient it is not very
efficient but it's um really indelible
really really indelible and this
dedication to experience is something
that we talk about a lot after the
bottle before we talk more about
experience I'd like to talk to you about
this idea of excuse me three words I was
pressed to come up with a mission
statement around 2008 and I was
resistant and I had I had deadlines I
have to go to this meeting I had to
unveil this mission statement and I
couldn't do it I was was I was
practicing my excuses actually on the
way to this meetings like well I was
really busy or I had to do this or this
broke or this failed and and then I
realized that if we just got really
really good at three things three words
if we could remember three words that
would take us a really really long way
and the three words that I came up with
in 2008 are they're sinking of
deliciousness hospitality and
sustainability there's other words that
we use now too
at Blue Bottle coffee but those are the
heart those are the ones anybody that
works for us we say that one time and
they remember it forever they're
important lessons it's not always in
that order but usually in that order so
I like the three words we talked a lot
about it so that's oh and then and then
being so inspired by Japanese coffee
gear Japanese modes of preparation I
found a great lease and mint Plaza 2008
and in a beautiful building and a
horrible horrible block and that since
come up that this gorgeous building and
that was the place where I was able to
really explore a lot of my ideas about
these Japanese coffee techniques I
didn't want to make it kiss at ten but I
wanted to make something that was our
expression of it that was our homage to
these ideas about serving Japanese
coffee as perfectly as possible so
that's MIT Plaza hopefully some of you
will drop by so we talked a lot about
about experience at Blue Bottle and the
more I do this the more I realize that
this taste of this coffee is negated
it's meaningless if people don't have a
good time when they're doing it that
part of our product is the experience
that people have while they are drinking
it or before or after
so thinking very deeply about removing
obstacles about having a great
experience making it clear making it
legible I think experience is the
totality of sensory and emotional data
both unconscious and conscious that we
absorb you know it's the taste of the
drink sound stereo makes it's the
anxiety of seeing a word you've never
that you might not know how to pronounce
on a menu playlist
you know what obstacles have we removed
from people's paths so we don't have to
have them think about it we don't have
to trouble them with it those is is
their sincere human interaction sincere
warm helpful human act interaction at
every place before people actually need
it those are the types of experiences we
think about that our our part of our
product and though that's the thing that
as we grow we have to be very very
assiduous in making sure we're not just
maintaining certain standards but
they're improving there's this word
maintain I used to get asked it a lot
fortunately I haven't been asked it in a
while how are you gonna maintain your
standards as you grow and there is no
maintain you can't you can't like hold
on to this thing you have to improve as
as you grow in order for this whole
thing to make sense we have to have this
this idea that we're getting better and
better and we're adding more things
we're being on a wider stage but we're
improving as we go because otherwise
that's a horrible way to live right
thinking about like oh remember how
great our coffee was in 2014 it's like
oh yeah that was really great nobody
wants to live like that and I choose not
to live like that
so everything we do at Blue Bottle is
with the assumption that we can improve
the experience and the coffee that
people have as we add cafes as we add
employees as we add guests as we add
coffee growers and then there's moments
moments I feel like our subunits of
experience moment secrete to form these
experiences it's a it sounds kind of
weird it's a future memory on display
when we're thinking about cafe design I
think about like little moments that
people might have and there's this
philosopher I'll read Bergson show of
hands you're my new best friend Jennifer
um that wrote a book called mind and
matter that talks about memory in that
way we don't have to go into that
necessarily but it was very interesting
for me to see how that is connected that
you can have you can plan you can
premeditate a beautiful experience for
someone and they can have that
experience without actually
participating in it it's if you see a
little nook you're in line you see a
little nook you see a cozy place you see
somebody eating an affogato or something
delicious you can have that moment of
having a memory of that experience in
the future and that creates a desire and
so this this idea from army barracks in'
has been very interesting important to
me when we're talking about cafe design
to let people see and plan for something
beautiful in their future as well as
have something in the present moment and
you know and there's there's things that
we want to get out of people's way you
know I'm gonna have that slide you know
that's what we're trying to weed away
from people's experience you know that
is a sad face emoticon right there
you know you've got like an empty sugar
container you've got drips you've got a
dirty glass on the on the condiment
counter and those are the things even if
you don't notice it even
if you don't take sugar in your coffee
you're gonna project that moment into
your future too it's like oh maybe not
consciously maybe not so maybe only
subconsciously but you're gonna see that
and you're gonna see a lack it's like oh
if they can't keep their sugar filled
what else can't they do if I'm noticing
that you know what else is lacking that
I'm not noticing so I stress a little
bit about moments like that we have our
successes and our failures and nobody's
perfect but it's moments like these that
I'm working very hard with my team at
Blue Bottle to try to weed out so that's
the future you know we're working on
different ways of experiencing our
coffee
ways of removing barriers to enjoying
this experience of our coffee this is a
shop we're opening in Berkeley on
Shattuck and University a very busy
corner and the what we're experimenting
with is this notion of gathering a
counter is a barrier so how do you
remove those barriers how do you let
people interact as they choose with a
barista sometimes people just want to
say the word coffee and if somebody
makes something delicious other times
people want to enjoy the process people
want to have a moment of seeing somebody
else enjoy the process and projecting
themselves into that future that
possible future for them so the more we
think about experiences the more I feel
like the act of designing a cafe is to
strip away to remove everything
extraneous to remove barriers from these
experiences in moments and you can do it
yourself
gentlemen I work with very inspiring
gentlemen I work with his name's Ariane
and he's our head of store design when I
met him he gave me a little graph like
this it's called an emotional journey
map it's it's quite common it blew my
mind but it's quite common than to
design field this was a little I don't I
didn't write down the cafe right oh good
okay this is a cafe up in Sonoma County
um that I went to and all it is is sort
of a
it's a subjective emotional map of how
I'm feeling at certain points and if you
do this enough times I have like a
little note taker on my phone and I do
this every so often still you know it
was a bummer of a time I didn't get my
toast it that started out so great there
were cute dogs in front you know but you
do this enough time that you realize
everybody does this when they walk into
a place that you do this every time you
like catch the bus or you wait for an
appointment you know
there's this this emotional journey this
this turbulence you know maybe it's on a
small scale you know at the end of the
day I mean you're not getting my toast
wasn't wasn't that shattering for me but
you know it was very illuminating for me
to do this and I encourage you to do
this yourself if you're interested in
any form of retail and he's any form of
experiential pursuits I encourage you to
do this and just see see where you are
it's it's it was um very interesting for
me you can do it in a large scale like
this when you go have some retail
experience and then um when we were
getting our new service where made
there's actually a little journey that I
projected into the future of guests
experience when we were having it made
the emotional journey that I was
thinking of was three steps with this
new service where you'll see it in Palo
Alto if you see it so the first is if
you see the service where from a
distance it just looks like white cups
you know no big deal white cups you get
closer and you realize that they're not
perfect circles there's an organic shape
to them they're a little bit more
huggable they're a little bit more you
can be show more affection to them I
guess that they encouraged that I think
those organic shapes what you don't know
is that these cups were made for us by a
company called Quinto and the proportion
of the cups was exactly to our orders
each cup to the milliliter is exactly
the volume that we have asked them to
make and so the experience you don't
understand when you're interacting with
those cups is that the proportions are
exactly as we want them and then the
final step is obviously the cup goes on
the saucer and then you're drinking your
cup and you don't see the logo anywhere
else if you don't see a blue bottle you
know look over here
we're not grabbing people's attention
but we're allowing them to notice and
hopefully be charmed by this moment of
seeing the logo under the cup where it
belongs
coffee should be primary the logo should
be underneath and so even for something
as simple as thinking about service
where you know you can think about so
much emotional turbulence so much
churning so many stories I'm wondering
if you think it's very exhausting to
live with me um actually yes so that's
the end of that experiential part we
walked away from 20% of our revenues
last year
will that got your attention uh we used
to do coffee wholesale for many coffee
companies especially very good ones that
can be 7080 percent of their revenue
it was never huge for us that was 20
percent but 20 percent is not nothing
and I remember this moment I was in Los
Angeles I stopped at a very good coffee
place in Silver Lake owned and operated
by a very good roastery had a nice time
walking back to the car like two blocks
away and I see gelateria and they say
you know proudly serving this coffee
roasters coffee and they misspelled the
name of the coffee roaster I did they're
like their sign was right across the
street and down and to me that really
summed up the perils of trusting
somebody else to care about your product
nobody loves your coffee more than you
do it's just the way it is and so with
wholesale I was feeling more and more
out of control about the experience we
were giving people I would you know
people start with the best of intentions
nobody signs up with a coffee roaster
with the intention
oh we're gonna serve your coffee
horribly you know but nobody has that
intention but that's how it works out
because if you stop caring just for a
little little bit then you know all hell
breaks loose sometimes and you get stuff
like this we confiscated that from a
wholesale account and you know people
just freelance your logo and and anyway
it seems to be much more shocking to me
than to you but trust me it was a
horrible sign that we did not want out
in the world so we made a decision a
tough decision to walk away from
wholesale walk away from 20% of our
revenue in the service of our future
guests in the service of the growers of
our coffee in the service of the people
who are producing our coffee at our
roaster ease in our four roaster ease so
we don't do that anymore and it's been
great it's allowed me to focus so that
made my life a little happier it's been
great for everybody who works at Blue
Bottle to just focus in it's been a real
point of pride with people who've been
around the coffee industry for a long
time and know the perils of coffee
roasting for wholesale it's been a real
point of pride that we don't do that
does anybody ever read the myth of
sisyphus by commune very good hands are
shooting up left and right and that's
kind of like it's kind of what it's like
in a wholesale coffee wholesale you know
the boulder always crashes down and you
know you train people you hope for the
best but at the end of the day the
bowler always crashes down come whose
point was that Sisyphus was basically a
very happy man
because he knew what the task ahead was
but for me it's like I could never I
could never really get there so um see I
don't want to talk forever so we've had
a couple acquisitions we've had a couple
funding rounds just to go over those
closely so the history of that in 2008
there's a small minority investment and
I worked with a very smart and
cyclopentyl man named Johnny spurn that
worked for Kohlberg Ventures that was a
little bit of my graduate school I guess
you could say I was introduced to
Kohlberg ventures by a non-profit in
Oakland nonprofit that I have a lot of
affection for called inner-city advisors
they match up growing businesses with
pro bono business advice literally when
I met with inner-city advisors the first
time I did not know what piano stood for
profit and loss very good and then there
was a large round in 2012 that's where I
met my business partner Brian mean who's
now the executive chair of Blue Bottle
coffee also a Stanford Graduate Business
School graduate David Bowman who is now
CFO and CEO oh it's got a lot of letters
David does and so that has really helped
us helped me kind of step back from the
financial part from the fundraising part
from the stuff I won't i won't do part
and concentrate on things like spending
a lot of time on service we're spending
a lot of time on store design spending a
lot of time on how the coffee tastes
really focusing because the one thing is
I take this very personally as you might
have noticed because it's personal you
know I started it in 186 square feet and
I basically did everything I you know
designed a lot of the shops I still have
a lot of input in the design of the
shops I remember and you know and my
son used to my son - was twelfth and he
used to come with me he's tagged along
and you know just like little things
like those are the approved plans from
our roastery in 2009 it was you know
there's this health inspector in Alameda
County I won't say his name although I
am tempted to and it was just so
grueling it was so brutal I had to call
in every favor everything I could do to
get those plans passed so when we got
those plans passed and we could have
permission to build our roastery it was
a an amazing moment and so my family has
shared in those moments from the very
beginning and even though we have 22 now
we might have 35 this time next year
it feels no less personal and so on that
note I want to talk about constraints on
our growth as a composer named Brian Eno
as a great line any constraint is part
of the skeleton that you build the
composition on including your own
incompetence and I that really struck me
when I read that I think he's very smart
and good writer and the first 10 years
of Blue Bottle the formative first
decade you could say we're really built
around my own incompetence my failings
around not being capable of making
certain compromises not being too
devoted to efficiency the quirks of my
taste the insistence on finding an
underlining narrative around everything
we were doing about having a deeply
personal level of control over hopefully
what is a charmingly didactic tone of
voice
all of these ascent Rissa teas and
missteps kind of became sort of our
founding path and they filled our shops
they made us interesting to guests and
so the question you know we're facing
I'm facing and those of us at Blue
Bottle who are working on growth are
facing is like how do you scale
incompetence how do you scale
inefficiency you know that's a real
challenge for
me as we add smart accomplished
pedigreed experienced people to our
growing business there's a temptation to
do the things that smart accomplished
pedigreed experienced people do them
which is to say not the way I'm used to
doing them and so that's my quandary you
know how do I make a case for the
illogical how do I advocate how do I be
an advocate for the incompetence that
got me here talking to you at stanford
university without fatally hampering the
financial or operational success of our
business charting a path forward that
improves the experience of our future
guests but still keeps this this this
idea that everything is not perfect in
terms of the functioning of the business
that it should not be perfect that
perfect is that sheen of perfectionist
is one step away from premeditation hum
which is one step away from staleness
and so yeah our guests are counting us
to be better and better every year and
how do we do it
that's the question i'm not sure i do
know that doors open for us they have
for the last 13 years and probably for
the next 13 I happily suspect but I have
gotten used to solutions presenting
themselves at just the right time doors
open at just the right time there's an
author I love his name is Marcel Proust
II wrote a novel a very long novel
called in search of lost time
Jennifer hands up yes you know that very
good anybody else chopin's hmm anyway
that in the second volume there's a
great passage that really gave gave me
hope when I came came across it it's
speaking of doors opening it's the the
passage goes but sometimes illumination
comes to the rescue at the very moment
when it all seems lost we have knocked
on every door and they open
nothing until at last we stumble
unconsciously against the only one
through which we can enter the kingdom
we have sought in vain for a hundred
years and it opens and that image really
stuck with me and so hopefully with all
of our team's help and a little bit of
help from mr. Marcel Proust we will
continue to figure out how to scale
incompetence in an interesting way
thank you alright there's questions and
answers yes first hand so I was
wondering I want your website there was
no wait because you really emphasize on
product and experience right right there
was no way from me like actually figured
out from the direct sales that's your
website that how something else it felt
about that since the Africans are
twinkles are in a blink automatic so
what's the plan how do you incorporate
that kind of experience because that
would directly feed you what people are
thinking about a copier yeah it's very
interesting question so we have a
gentleman who's very interested and
passionate about our coffee which i
think is really lovely and he was saying
why don't we have a mechanism on our
website whereby he can write a review of
that coffee or others can or he can read
the reviews written by others rate them
yeah what's the plan hmm
where do you think no I'm deeply deeply
interested that you have a great
experience with your coffee if you do
not and you email support and you say
this twinkle thing I hated it they're
gonna they're going to apologize and
they're going to get some coffee to you
that they think you're gonna like and
that to me is critical to this exchange
the cacophony of online reviewing that
seems like something that I don't really
understand or frankly I wouldn't I
wouldn't want I would die a little bit
if like I saw like you know these
streams of reviews that we couldn't
control or edit obviously I want to make
everybody happy but I want people to to
talk to us about it so that's just my
cultural issue with that idea of online
reviews it's not disparaging your need
for that and you know that is a miss
that we can't provide that for you but I
don't think in terms of engineering
resources that would be the top of our
list to do that sorry yeah yes anybody
else just the front okay but I will okay
you know how do you reconcile yourself
to have already made coffee in like
venues that might not be like oh yeah so
the question is we have these very cute
little cartons of our new orleans-style
iced coffee that are in many many whole
foods and other places and cafeterias
and we're soon to release a black coffee
so for me that critical distinction is
we're not trusting anybody to make that
fee we're not asking anybody here the
rules for preparing it you have to stick
to the rules what we're doing is we're
saying this is a product we totally
believe that's just as delicious as what
we get in our shops and why shouldn't
you go to Whole Foods and buy it so you
can have an awesome trip to the beach
you know it's a way of scaling exactly
our intentions obviously we have to
trust that the you know the checker at
Whole Foods is going to be nice to you
you know there there are things that are
out of our control but the that primary
participation in the product is in fact
100% under our control provided they get
it to you during the date they should
get it and they don't leave it in the
hot Sun you know like all those basic
things that we can trust Whole Foods to
take advantage of so I've in my mind is
a very critical distinction between
trusting somebody else to make something
for a guest under our flag or a product
that we have absolute control over last
question or is yeah okay you've been I
feel like everybody oh sorry sir sorry
thank you yeah so very nicely mentioning
that he thought we had a lot of
attention to detail and that and if I'm
understanding your question correctly
why do you think others don't have as
much I don't think anybody at mislike I
don't care about the details you know
and in point of fact that slide that I
showed to you shows you that we are not
in control of everything I would like to
be in control of you know in terms of
the that dirty cup and the sugar being
out although we try our best so I think
everybody tries hard to have attention
over details everybody says it's
important
but do you invest in it do you have
processes in place to execute it I think
that's the critical difference is the
investment and that energy I don't think
it's about the intention
you